[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم اوكرانيا تاكدوا تسليمها
اول دفعه من صواريخنا سيمز المتطوره وذلك
تزامنا مع اشتداد المعارك بين الجيشين
الروسي والاوكراني في محاور خرسون وبخموط
ودمباس وفي وقت قال فيه الكريم لينه منفتح
على المفاوضات مع اوكرانيا لكنها مستحيله
الان بسبب رفضك
انطلاقه فعاليات قمه المناخ في مصر بحضور
اكثر من 100 وعشرين من قاده وزعماء العالم
والمنظمات الدوليه القمه ستتضمن مناقشات
بشان قضايا ابرزها الانتقال العادل لتنفيذ
الالتزامات المناخيه والامن الغذائي
والتمويل المبتكر للمناخي والتنميه
في باكستان حزب انصاف بزعمت عمران يرجى
مسيره كانت ستتجه غدا ملهور الى العاصمه
للمطالبه بانتخابات مبكرا خان يشترط
استقاله مسؤولين يتهممهم بتدبير محاوله
ويطالب رئيس البلاد
تضمن تحقيق العداله
فيسبوك
هي الاكبر في تاريخ الشركه وقد تشمل الالف
الموظفين
الى اللقاء